have you ever gotten a notice that looks
like this it looks like a scam right it
looks like it can't possibly be true
but this is a notice of a class action
settlement and there's actually a very
good chance that this is on the level
and
it's possible that you stand to make
some money off of it or
at least get something of value but
you'd be forgiven if you thought that
this was complete nonsense because i
mean
just look at it look lawyers are good at
writing things down they are not great
at graphic design
but the biggest question is what do you
do when you get a notice like this how
do you know if it's real
well as it happens your favorite bird
lawyer has actually litigated and
settled countless numbers of class
action settlements worth hundreds of
millions of dollars
so let's talk about the good the bad and
the extremely ugly
about class action lawsuits and most
importantly what you should do if you
get a notice of class action settlement
so join me as i spill some legal tea
sponsored by trade coffee so this is no
joke i really did receive this notice of
class action settlement related to an
epic games lawsuit apparently at some
point i played either fortnight or
rocket league and i might be entitled to
some money or some benefits as a result
of this settlement it makes sense
because i will never get that time that
i spent on fortnight back
so i would really really like to be
compensated for that and the things that
we're going to talk about today will
relate to this particular
class action lawsuit but it should apply
to just about any class action notice
that you receive
so let's first talk about what is a
class action suit because this is one of
the most misunderstood things in all of
law
generally when you have a lawsuit you
personally sue somebody else because the
dollar amounts in question are worth
getting compensation for what you think
you were wronged over
but a class action is the opposite of
that it's where a lot of people were
probably harmed in very very small ways
that
it would never make sense for them to
individually file suit but instead if
you wrap
all of them together the class of people
all of those people who are in the same
situation
can get compensation from a company or
another individual
and when you group them all together it
makes it worthwhile to file suit
part of it is a punitive reason we don't
want companies to engage
in misbehavior that they'd never
otherwise be punished for
because simply the individuals would
never think to hire their own personal
attorney
so every state and the federal system
has laws on the books to allow people to
file a class action
and a class action gets this reputation
that's sort of like rico if you
file a class action then it's a super
super serious lawsuit and
a class action can deal with large
dollar amounts especially because you're
aggregating a whole bunch of claims
but just because it's a class action
doesn't mean that it's
necessarily a super scary or super nasty
lawsuit
sometimes class actions settle for
hundreds of millions of dollars
sometimes they go to trial and sometimes
they're simply dismissed
and no one gets anything but the most
important thing to remember about a
class action is that it requires a class
a group of people who suffered a similar
injury that
all of their injuries and all the things
that happened to them are very very
similar because a court is not going to
engage in a class action
if it has to individually look at every
single person
if the calculation that goes into the
damages for each individual person is
different
it's probably not likely to give rise to
a class action the class has to be
very similar the damages that they
suffered have to be very similar and it
has to be easy for the court to
ascertain
all of these things together because
they're dealing with potentially
hundreds
thousands and sometimes even millions of
people so imagine if you will a person
runs into a crowd and just starts
punching people now
it could be that that person has punched
a hundred people in that crowd and you
might think that could give rise to a
class action but probably not
because maybe one person was punched in
the stomach one person was punched
in the face one person suffered a
broken bone and one person was barely
damaged at all
because all of those injuries are so
fact specific
that's not the kind of thing that gives
rise to a class action well on the other
hand let's look at something that could
be easily adjudicated as a class action
let's imagine that there's a big cell
phone provider
and let's say that they improperly put a
one
dollar fee on your bill that shouldn't
be there and let's say they bill that
out to a million customers
well it's really easy to ascertain those
people you just look at the spreadsheet
of what people were charged what fees
and the damages are all the same it's
just that one extra fee that shouldn't
be there that's exactly the kind of fact
situation that's likely to give rise to
a valuable and valid class action
lawsuit so now let's turn to this
fortnight and rocket league lawsuit and
use that as an example of what happens
when a class action has filed and here
because this court case has already
gotten to the settlement stage
all the documents are helpfully
displayed right on the court settlement
website
and yes this website is legitimate it's
not meant to look good it's just meant
to be legally sufficient
so what the plaintiffs originally
alleged is that the makers of fortnite
and rocket league
engaged in some unfair business
practices and in particular if you dig
into the complaint what you'll see is
the plaintiff alleged that a lot of
minors
entered into transactions on these video
games and weren't allowed to back
out of these transactions because they
were minors and it also alleges some
other unfair business practices
as well as some claims related to random
loot crates and people spending a
thousand
virtual dollars on loot crate related
things we'll never know if that was in
fact true or not because one of the
benefits of settlement is that you don't
have to go through the expense of
discovery
and the whole trial to get to the truth
of the matter asserted you can just
settle and say that you're not admitting
anything or you're not admitting faults
if you're the defendant
and here the party's engaged in
litigation but eventually came to the
conclusion
that it was in everyone's best interest
to settle the claims instead of
spending money on the litigation now
when you come to that conclusion
it's not as easy as just signing on the
dotted line in fact
both the plaintiffs and the defendants
have to go to the court to get the court
to sign off
on the settlement itself it has to be
court approved the court has to make
sure that
the class of people are actually being
fairly compensated and that everything
else is
on the level now in addition to that you
have to determine certain things like
what is the class
and here based on the notice it says
that you're a member of the settlement
classif at any time between july 1 2015
and february 25th 2021
you had a fortnight or rocket league
account that you used to play either
game on any device in any mode and a
exchanged in-game virtual currency for
any in-game benefit
or b made a purchase of virtual currency
or other in-game benefit for use within
fortnite or rocket league so if you fit
that description you're entitled to some
relief
from the court and if you look at the
settlement agreement the lawyers
estimate that there are approximately 12
million people who have accounts who
played the games and
fit that description across both
fortnite and rocket league
and now we get to the part that everyone
is waiting for what could you possibly
get out of this settlement
well here the defendants have agreed to
spend up to 26.5 million dollars
but that's unfortunately not what the
class is going to get and here's where
things get a little bit ugly and where
i'm afraid we're going to have to spill
a little bit of legal tea
because the thing is the plaintiff's
lawyers are not only negotiating on
behalf
of the class of people who are injured
but they're also negotiating on behalf
of themselves because they're going to
get a cut of this payout
sometimes that payout might be ten
percent of the class payout sometimes it
might be fifty or sixty percent of the
class payout but the good news is that
the court is supervising all of this and
they're trying to make sure that the
lawyers aren't taking too too much from
the class settlement look
the lawyers have to get paid if it
weren't for them these suits would never
be filed but there's a fine line between
being compensated fairly for your time
and also just getting a huge windfall
but in addition to the plaintiff's
lawyers there's also the class
representative
to be able to file a class action you
have to have an individual who
represents
the rest of the class fairly and that
person or individuals
also need to be compensated generally
they're not paid all that much
maybe five to ten thousand dollars at
most and sure that's a lot of money but
your average class
representative is going to put in a lot
of work they're probably going to need
to be deposed they'll have to
talk to the lawyers and i wouldn't wish
that on anyone so
in the grand scheme of things the payout
for the class representative is usually
not a huge amount
as represented by the total payout so
how much will the class actually get
well that depends on how many people
actually take up the settlement because
it's a bit of a moving target the more
people that sign up for the class action
the less each individual gets and
believe me the fact that i'm making a
video about this
is going to give the lawyers who are in
charge of this settlement both on the
defense and the plaintiff side
a complete heart attack because now i've
publicized this
suit and the uptick on the number of
people who are going to
ask for a class payment is probably
going to go through the roof so
sorry guys so what will any individual
class member get as a result
if they participate in this class action
well you have to look at the settlement
agreement but they might be able to get
a maximum of fifty dollars
depends on what kind of damages you
suffered or you have the option to
receive payment in virtual dollars v
bucks on fortnite or rocket league
up to a maximum of thirteen thousand
five hundred which they estimate to be
worth about a hundred dollars if you
have to purchase them in game now of
course the virtual dollars are not
actually worth a hundred dollars to the
game manufacturers despite the fact that
that's how much it might cost you if you
wanted to buy them
so they would much rather you take your
settlement payment in the form of the
virtual dollars instead of an actual
cash payment so people who are members
of this putative class have a couple of
options they can
go to this website they can sign up and
they can say that they actively want the
additional benefit of either the cash
or the virtual dollars as part of a
payment for this
class action lawsuit people of course
can do nothing as well
that's what most people do they look at
these emails and these notices and they
think that this is a complete scam
they don't want to provide their
personal information and they just
simply do nothing
and this particular settlement provides
that if they don't do anything they will
at least get a thousand virtual dollars
theoretically also you could write in to
the settlement administrator and you
could say that you don't want to
participate in this
settlement agreement and you can exclude
yourself from the class the main benefit
there is that
regardless of what happens in the class
you might be able to file suit on
your own behalf but you'd never want to
do that because the dollar amounts are
way way too small and additionally you
can also attend the hearing
on this settlement agreement because
right now we're in the preliminary
approval stage the court has looked at
this settlement
both the plaintiffs and the defendants
are advocating that the court should
approve this settlement
but they need more information they need
to know how many people are going to
sign up for the class
they need to know how many people object
how many people don't want to be
included
in this class because if there are too
many people who reject the settlements
then the court might have to tell the
parties to go back to the drawing board
and here's one of the craziest things
sometimes if too many people sign up for
the benefits of the settlement agreement
it kind of blows up the whole deal we
saw this in the equifax class action
where
they offered up to 150 per person whose
privacy rights were violated when
equifax completely screwed the pooch in
terms of user privacy
and then so many people signed up to get
the 150 dollars it broke the bank and
the parties had to go back to the
drawing board again and theoretically
since
i'm publicizing this video that might
happen here too
yeah sorry about that but effectively
this is the same process that everyone
goes through in class action settlements
it starts with notifying the potential
class usually through email but maybe
it's through the telephone
using these janky notices that look like
a scam
then you have to go to these websites
that look like they came out of geo
cities in
1994 and you then have to provide your
personal information to sign up for the
class on the hopes
that you'll get some sort of payout from
the settlement agreement and of course
then you have to wait for the court to
approve the final settlements
and then maybe a year or two later you
might actually get a
check in the mail or some virtual
dollars deposited
into your virtual bank account it takes
a very very long time
and while we spilled the tea about class
actions i'd never spill my cup of coffee
because i get my coffee from trade
after all a lawyer is only as good as
their last cup of coffee trade is great
not only because they have a huge
selection of your favorite coffees but
they also have a fantastic quiz to get
you matched up with coffee
recommendations based on your personal
preferences
i have a very specific taste in coffee
basically i want something that
tastes like hot chocolate and pairs well
with milk lots and lots of milk and
sugar
and trade was able to find me a perfect
roast and now since the weather is
getting warm
they have a huge selection of cold brews
as well with trade you can discover new
coffees from the nation's top roasters
trade matches you to your own personal
selection of coffee and conveniently
delivers it directly to you
and if you know what you like they
probably already have your favorite
roaster in stock at a fantastic price
so if you'd like to try trade coffee
legal eagles will get 50
off of their first bag when they sign up
and get free shipping just click on the
link in the description take the quiz
and choose your frequency whether you
want one bag or a subscription
and then rate your coffee so your
suggestions get even better you can even
choose whole beans or your preferred
grind it's really the best coffee
website out there
so get 50 off your first order by
clicking on the link in the description
or use the promo code legal50 at
checkout
plus clicking that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis
class actions coffee whatever leave your
objections in the comments and
check out this other legal eagle video
here i think you'll really like it so
click on this video or i'll see you
in court